[拍手]
[音楽]
ええええええ
ん
今日はドクター始めた皆さんカレー3種御存知だろうか
まさにさっき作ったんですけどもこちらのカレーメシこれなんか見た目がやっぱり
カップラーみたいな仮説してるんですけどもいいですねちゃんと影になるんですよもう
分かりづら関根名機までしておりますここに米印であの僕めっちゃ好きなんでしょかね
にしてめっちゃ好きで週1にぐらいで食ってるんですけどもそれでも帰って来珍しい
日間なきゃいけ
e カップラーメンと間違われやすいカレーにしたんですけどっ
ってに美味しいんですよねこれおいしいだけじゃなくてなんか最近 cm でもやって
たんですけども溺れないんですよこれかプラムの画面だったらなんかこう
揺れるとシルバーだから来ビシャビシャとかなってリールのメインアップ rom
ケルダーなんですけども仮縁ですロボットしてるんで惚れにくいんですよこれすごいて
相当あの私結果手荒な人みんなんでなく食べたりスって結構こうしちゃうんですよ
ボラボラっとそれがない
で相当なメリットなんで高原の実験はこうれないと言われているこのカレーにしどこ
までだったら個別に食べるのか
いろんな状況下で検証していきたいと思いますでテレビ cm でぺたらなんかがた
ことな道をバイクのあのサイドカラーみたいなところに入って乗って刑事がう
こうやってたやつですそれは本当なのかどうかも米ちょっといろいろ検証していきたい
と思いますとりあえずも完成ですねキャッチで産んだよこれ
ゴゾ待って混ぜるだけで完成します最初はじゃあなんですけどを混ぜて来てすぐに粘り
ティクビってこれこぼれにくいはってともに行っちゃうんですよね実験用に2個付け
ちゃいました
あっあこの見る少々でしょう2となんかカップ麺感なんですけどまずっとねすごいです
よ
[音楽]
さあみてくださいこのドローリカーこれはで気さくなんでもうチョコにドロドロするん
ですよ
結構かたまりませんでしたマジで後から作って積んでもう傾けでもほぼ動かないって
これ見てこの粘りって言っ
[拍手]
えっぐわぁ
た新時代の食べ物それはおいしくあってこぼれない華麗めし殊衆国の料理今日はそんな
金水のこぼれない耐久度を調べてきたいと思うでないか
えっ
[音楽]
頑張りん
れます
ピッ
[音楽]
これは当然だろう
悪い
[音楽]
[笑い]
ブーブー
[音楽]
ウールワース
笑っていた
ああああああ
ana
me
[音楽]
ん
dj
悪い
[音楽]
ていたなんかも
ん
[音楽]
ブーブー
ブーバーし
んわー
ん
レジのさあ他の突破ショ撮ってもいいです
生産で研究したらさ
8万円ぐらい違うだけ
はこれ関係ないです関係なくないお前は行った後に点検してんだかっ
俺でもいいですねいやお前だって俺じゃないですってお前だって俺じゃないですお前だ
から言ってんだとこれじゃないかメルズの狙いですよカメラに浮かべないです俺やって
ないですやってるよやってないで確認するカンマを確認するぞ
ばまあそれ
ブーブーやったら先生も aws ジャンヌーベル取った are you do
マッハ
[音楽]
その中入ります
me
[音楽]
これ
スパッません
はぁ
私都合
入ってます入ってますよね入ってますよねー
くん
[音楽]
ブーバーで
re 3分
ぷっ
姉をもせず入っちゃっねぇー
どうぞ